for my husband it was love at first
sight here's what happened years ago
Rudy who I had strictly put in the
friend zone at the time came over to my
house and met my dad a pharmaceutical
scientist who had just retired after
bringing a drug to market my dad said
you probably wouldn't have heard of it
it's for ips idiopathic pulmonary
fibrosis
Rudy paused for a long time and then he
said that's the disease that took my
father's life 15 years ago Rudy says
that this is the moment he fell in love
with my father even though it was too
late for my dad to save his he felt that
destiny had delivered us this
full-circle moment in my family we have
a special love for my father's
inventions and in particular we have a
reverence for his patents we have framed
patents on the wall in our house and
there's a recognition in our family that
everything I've been able to do College
Law School health justice work all of it
is because America enabled my father to
fulfill his potential as an inventor
last year I met the director of the US
Patent Office for the first time and I
sent my family a selfie from that office
in Virginia I got so many emojis back
you would have thought I had met Beyonce
but truth be told I was actually there
to talk about a problem how our outdated
patent system is fueling the high cost
of medicines and costing lives today
over 2 billion people live without
access to medicines and against this
global crisis drug prices are
skyrocketing including in wealthier
countries 34 million Americans have lost
a family member or a friend in the last
five years not because the treatment
didn't exist but because they couldn't
afford it
rising drug costs are pushing families
into homelessness seniors into
bankruptcy and parents to crowdfunding
treatment for their critically ill
children there are many reasons for this
crisis but one is the outdated patent
system that America tries to export to
the rest of the world
the original intention behind the patent
system was to motivate people to invent
by rewarding them with a time-limited
monopoly but today that intention has
been distorted beyond recognition
corporations have teams of lawyers and
lobbyists whose sole job is to extend
patent protection as long as possible
and they've kept the patent office busy
it took a hundred and fifty five years
for the US Patent Office to issue its
first five million patents it took just
27 years for it to issue the next five
million we haven't gotten drastically
more inventive corporations have gotten
drastically better at gaming the system
drug patents have exploded between 2006
and 2016 they doubled but consider this
the vast majority of medicines
associated with
new drug patents are not new nearly
eight out of ten are for existing ones
like insulin or aspirin my organization
a team of lawyers and scientists
recently conducted an investigation into
the 12 best selling drugs in America we
found that on average there are a
hundred and twenty five patents filed on
each medicine often for things we've
known how to do for decades like putting
two pills into one the higher a patent
wallet company built the longer they
hold on to their monopolies and with no
one to compete with they can set prices
at whim and because these are medicines
and not designer watches we have no
choice but to pay the patent wall is a
strategy to block competition not for
the 14 years maximum that America's
founders originally envisioned or the 20
years allowed by law today but for 40
years or more meanwhile prices on these
drugs have continued to increase
68% since 2012 that's 7 times the rate
of inflation and people are struggling
or even dying because they can't afford
the meds now I want to be really clear
about something this isn't about making
the pharmaceutical industry the bad guy
what I'm talking about today is whether
the system we created to promote
progress is actually working as intended
sure the pharmaceutical companies are
gaming the system but they're gaming it
because they can because we have failed
to adapt this system to meet today's
realities the government is handing out
one of the most prized rewards in
business the opportunity to create a
product that is protected from
competition and asking for less and less
in return on our behalf imagine awarding
a ha
Pulitzer Prizes to one author for the
same book it doesn't have to be this way
we can create a modern patent system to
meet the needs of a 21st century society
and to do that we need to reimagine the
patent system to serve the public not
just corporations so how do we do it
five reforms first we need to stop
handing out so many patents back under
the kennedy administration in an effort
to curb rising drug costs a congressman
from tennessee proposed an idea he said
if you want to tweak a drug and you want
to get another patent on it
the modified version has to be
significantly better therapeutically for
patients because of intense lobbying
this idea never saw the light of day but
a reimagined patent system would
resurrect and evolve the simple yet
elegant proposition the to get a patent
you have to invent something
substantially better than what's already
out there
this shouldn't be controversial as a
society we reserve the big rewards for
the big ideas we don't give Michelin
stars to chefs who just tweak a recipe
we give them to chefs who change how we
think about food and yet we hand out
patents worth billions of dollars for
minor changes it's time to raise the bar
second we need to change the financial
incentives of the Patent Office
right now the revenue of the Patent
Office is directly linked to the number
of patents that it grants that's like
private prisons getting paid more to
hold more people it naturally leads to
more incarceration not less the same is
true for patents third we need more
public participation right now the
patent system is like a black box it's a
two-way conversation but
the Patent Office and Industry you and I
aren't invited to that party but imagine
if instead the Patent Office became a
dynamic center for citizen learning and
ingenuity staffed not just by technical
experts and bureaucrats but also by
great Public Health storytellers with a
passion for science regular citizens
could get accessible information about
complex technologies like artificial
intelligence or gene editing enabling us
to participate in the policy
conversations that directly impact our
health and lives fourth we need to get
the right to go to court right now in
America after a patent is granted the
public has no legal standing only those
with a commercial interest usually other
drug companies have that right but I've
witnessed firsthand how lives can be
saved when everyday citizens have the
right to go to court
back in 2006 in India my organization
worked with patient advocates to
challenge legally unjust HIV drug
patents at a time when so many people
were dying because medicines were priced
out of reach we were able to bring down
the prices of medicines by up to 87%
on just three drugs we were able to save
health systems half a billion dollars
now cases like these can save millions
of lives and billions of dollars
imagine if Americans had the right to go
to court - and lastly we need stronger
oversight we need a independent unit
that can serve as a Public Advocate
regularly monitoring the activities of
the Patent Office and reporting to
Congress if a unit like this had existed
it would have caught for example the
Silicon Valley company theranos before
it got so many patents for blood testing
and landed a valuation of nine billion
dollars when in reality there was no
invention there at all this kind of
accountability is going to become
increasingly urgent in the age of 23 and
me important questions are being asked
about whether companies can patent and
sell our genetic information and our
patient data we need to be part of those
conversations before it's too late our
information is being used to create the
new therapies and when that moment of
diagnosis comes for me and my family
or for you and yours are we gonna have
to crowdfund
to save the lives of those we love
that's not the world I want to live in
it's not the world I want for my
two-year-old son my dad is growing older
now and he is still as quietly brilliant
and morally directed as ever sometimes
people ask us whether things get heated
between us the patent holding scientist
and his patent reforming lawyer daughter
it's such a profound misunderstanding of
what's at stake because this is not
about scientists versus activists or
invention versus protection this is
about people
our quest to invent and our right to
live my dad and I understand that our
ingenuity and our dignity go hand in
hand we are on the same side it is time
to reimagine a patent system that
reflects that knowing thank you
[Applause]
[Music]